hey everyone welcome
this is the second time that
i'm doing a trip report on the channel
the first time
i did one was covering my heroic
dose of magic mushrooms
and
that was five grams and
that was very profound and i made a
detailed video about that which you can
find
on our channel and also linked in the
bio below
i'm not sure how often i'll be doing
these trip reports
on my psychonautic adventures
i do really like
magic mushrooms the compound of
psilocybin and cilicin has been a
incredible mixture of creating
these neural modulations that
relax the
contracted individual identity into the
expansive non-dual
infinitude and
that's why it's really
micro dose friendly as well because
it is
being used also by
even the elite executors around our
planet and
entrepreneurs to
[Music]
again release the grips
on that default mode network
neuroscientifically and
enable the connectomix to be
firing and wiring new novel
connections across neural networks
that's why there's not only the
dissolving of the contracted
individual egoic identity but there's
also the novel
creative
gifts that rise up and blossom
and so that's why it's being used by so
many peak performers
across the world that's why
even the silicon valley elites are
leveraging it
it's been used as an entheogen meaning
unleashing god within it's very similar
to psychedelic mind manifesting
and it's been used for thousands of
years across the planet
to commune with god with the absolute
with infinity
to pierce the veilless veil the gateless
gate and to recognize
one's own true metaphysical nature and
that's why
2500 years ago at the top of the temple
of apollo at delphi and the greeks
wrote the delphic maxim know thyself
that's what entheogens do is they
trigger the inward
journey to know thyself
as the one infinite creator expressing
itself
and terence and dennis mckenna developed
out the stoned ape hypothesis
which is what i sort of started my day
with
around noon today this is again
being streamed on february 11
2021
and around noon was the
intention to undergo this microdose
that i had been saving for a couple
weeks to explore
and the day was sunny enough
it was clear enough on the schedule
and
it started with what
revelations were coming through
around the entheogen that specifically
magic mushrooms there are many other
entheogens that are used across the
planet
there's ayahuasca dmt 5meo dmt
from the buffalo various there's
the created lsd
by albert hoffman there's
mdma there's
iboga ibogaine peyote
there's many
planetary entheogens that are both
naturally secreted as well as created by
us to trigger these entheogenic
neural modulations that dissolve the ego
and that pierce that veilus veil to
the god realized state of recognizing
oneself as
that one infinite creator
and specifically as terence and
dennis pointed out the stoned ape
hypothesis
is something that i had been very
excited about over the last couple of
years and especially
last year being introduced
by one of my friends to the fusion of
chromosomes
2a and 2b and also to the development of
the fox p2 protein which is
instrumental in human language
and communication
these pieces started clicking more and
more together
that hundred thousand or more years ago
that there were these
evolutionary
especially upwards of five million years
ago we are
doing our best to understand this
evolutionary trajectory
but those first moments of in a sense
becoming bipedal and going up
on the two feet and walking
around and being more confident in being
in a pack that could then defend itself
from
a tiger or other encroaching animals
and to discover as the hypothesis
indicates a possibility is that
specifically magic mushrooms really
enjoy
the cow manure to grow in
and so to take the manure of animals
and then to have the magic mushrooms
growing in that and to be
the
the chimpanzee the ape that is walking
through
the great plains in the out of
africa hypothesis
to pluck that eat it several million
years ago
and then to slowly incrementally
recognize
what the nature of reality
is more and more to sort of
recognize that the grunt
can be altered and create meaning
from the grunts the vibration of the
vocal cords can create
communication the fusing of chromosomes
2a and 2b which chimps have but we don't
and then the development of the fox p2
protein
over that span of hundreds of thousands
of years
that got us to where we are at today
so it is very likely
that what we are today
is actually a product of magic mushrooms
and to
see that as a beautiful
moment in the evolutionary trajectory
the assisting of an entheogen
to the awakening of
the chimps
to their own true nature
as the one infinite creator expressing
itself
was so profound and it only really
became that understanding
of one infinite creator more and more as
we could put it
into stories especially and
drawings and words
to communicate across generations and
that was so profound
is that that art those cave paintings
from tens of thousands of years ago and
also the
initial writings were able to
pass along knowledge transgenerationally
on how to best
procure and harvest food as well as how
to build
shelters how to understand what the
nature of
the awareness and reality are
and so this is going to be
really important moving forward that we
recognize the profundity of entheogens
especially because that mycelium itself
is a billion years old you have the
intelligence of a billion years of
evolution
that works with 95 of
plants across the
planet that has a
mycorrhizal network two-way resource
exchange
underground where the mycelium brings up
nitrogen phosphorus and potassium and
water
and gives it to trees and plants
meanwhile the
trees especially the big mother trees
will sequester
additional carbon undergo photosynthesis
and distribute the sugars to the
mycelium
that billion year intelligence
of as paul stamet says the neurological
network of nature
and even in the couple last 100 million
years with trees and plants
that is so profound and the way that
just in the last
million or so years boop the chimpanzee
um and then gets evolved
up to that human level again the fusion
of chromosomes 2a and 2b and the
development of fox p2 protein look
into those they are very important and
insightful in understanding the stoned
ape
evolutionary trajectory so i don't know
how much i'm going to be doing these
trip reports how often i'm going to be
doing them
i'm really grateful to the healing
hustlers
both sky and sunny they are
extremely dear to my heart
i adore them so much and they have been
producing some of the best magic
mushrooms
across the united states and also they
have a really strong
lineage as well across different
people that are also contributing to
this
incredible high quality magic mushroom
and it's filling the need of people
across
the united states
across healing and across
awakening and i'm really grateful to
them and i adore them so much
and so their link is also here in the
bio for you to check out if you would
like to
reach out to them send them a dm
place an order yourselves again rapidly
being
decriminalized and even legalized
worldwide
as it should be because it catalyzes
planetary harmony
and awakening again that
billion-year-old intelligence
and so i'm not sure how often i'll do
these trip reports
but i do know that as i do these
it makes it more common
for more and more people around the
world
to become more and more comfortable with
the sharing of their psychonautics
and that's really important for us to
especially as skye and sunny both came
on our show and talked about
there's the there's this
african-american community and there's
the latino community in the asian
community
and the indians and the native americans
and the middle eastern and
in europe and there's all of these
pockets of people across the planet
that kind of see entheogens as a little
bit like
that's just some white people [ __ ] and
it's not
the more that people especially in the
positions of greatest leadership across
our planet
the fortune 500 ceos the un general
assembly the 2
200 billionaires across the planet the
225 000
ultra high net worth individuals and
families that have
assets of over 30 million us dollars and
the 535 people in the usa congress the
more these people of leadership across
our planet
undergo experiences unleashing god
within
what will happen is that they will no
longer see
the other as a separate contracted egoic
finite biological entity that they must
greedily take more of the pie from
but rather they will see it as a
planetary harmonic
orchestral process where the
other is actually the one infinite
creator expressing itself
through that unique expression and you
are your unique expression of that as
well
and in doing so that's what creates a
greater
amount of cohesion and maximizing
planetary prosperity and abundance and
harmony
and ecological
harmony where we're not disrupting our
ecological systems that actually sustain
us
and also where the
narratives that we'll be telling for
generations to come will be that
as we awaken to what entheogens
could do for us we
leverage that and then we
ignorantly criminalize them and then we
awakened again to
pierce the veilus veil and recognize
ourselves as one infinite creator
expressing itself
and so
it's both important to popularize trip
reports because it gets more people
around the world more comfortable with
this process
and also it is exciting because there
are profound
insights that came to me today during
this micro dose
and the level of intensity obviously
much different than five gram heroic
dose
is a single gram in this case it was
albino penis envy
and it was ingested around 12 40 p.m
today
and that the
one-fifth of the
amount that was taken on the heroic dose
it's so
subtle it's very very
subtle it's much like why people go
to the bar
and why they order a drink at the bar
the reason why people order a drink at
the bar
is because of the neuromodulatory
effects that alcohol creates that's why
people
talk about it so much as the sort of
loosening
of the anxiety so that people can feel a
little bit more socially free
and so it's very similar when you ingest
just the micro dose just a
gram of magic mushrooms is
the psilocybin in the cila sin when it
sort of
gets its effects on the body
on a micro dosing level it's so subtle
that you awaken to
the kingdom of god within you and
the
luke 17 21 and also leo tolstoy
that kingdom of god within you is
basically awaiting like the sufi
metaphysic says
that only the ignorant seek
what is already there yet it remains for
you to recognize it so do you recognize
yourself as one infinite creator
expressing itself and what
magic mushrooms does at that most subtle
gram level
is it enables the recognition
as rumi said of the diamond that is
already around your neck
so you no longer go from room to room
looking for it
but you recognize that the seer as saint
francis of assisi said as
ramana maharshi said the seer is god god
is the seer that's what the diamond is
that's already around your neck
and so it's really beautiful because
skye and sunny give these really great
notes along with the loving
carefully grown
magic mushrooms and here this is one of
skye's favorites and it really deeply
resonates with me as well
only a loser truly sees and i kept this
note with me
in my pocket and i kept referencing it
like every you know 15 minutes
throughout the experience because it was
so
interesting to look at and it's written
on this really nice sort of papyrus
looking
sheet and that's really fun about it and
in the grand ultimate scale of things
to unattach yourself from the
quote experience you are having is what
is meant by absolute realization
if you recognize yourself as intelligent
infinity expressing itself
and this as simply a dreamed creation
design you will recognize that
even the seer itself is a dream
even the seer itself is an agent of
infinity that it uses to experience
these dream creation designs
that way you no longer attach yourself
to seeing
and that's why the quote says only a
loser truly sees
because if you know yourself as the
absolute
then you know that even the seeing
itself
let alone the clouds of experience but
even the sky
of awareness that is the seer as god
even that is a dreamed agent
of what is agent less which is the
absolute
attribute-less
and so here's the
albino penis envy this is one of the
shots of it again this is
only one gram of it and this is the stem
itself and so i ripped open the stem
and right you can see here is you can
see the
the fibrous earthy
stock inside of the magic mushroom
where that silicin and psilocybin
is really densely concentrated that then
creates all of those neuromodulative
cascades and awakenings
and
this is really important because we're
trying to popularize
the trip report to the degree at which
people even feel comfortable
taking the pictures of their entheogens
and also making videos about their
experiences
and also making this more common more
and more people should
feel cool with
knowing what magic mushrooms look like
what they taste like they taste very
earthy
delicious very soft i love them a lot
plain
and also the approximate you can tell in
my hand that
right there that size is about a gram
and that the
popularization of the trip reports to
the degree at which people feel
comfortable sharing what happened on
their
and theogenic journeys so
even 20 minutes in i began feeling
really light
and that's a pretty common
process that occurs is that you get
a
very subtle kind of like this kind of
like the shirt to an extent
you get this really subtle
feeling of not being so physical
and that's why when we talk about it on
the show
we make it clear that if you're the
contracted
finite egoic separate entity
that that feels like it's
solely physicalism it feels like it's
just a biological entity and nothing
else
and that has no idea about its own even
awareness
let alone the shared eternal awareness
among us all let alone the absolute
it's very honed in on just the
clouds of experience
sensation perceptions feelings thoughts
emotions beliefs
and so that's what's called the monkey
mind in the spiritual traditions that
it's just monkey
monkeying around bouncing around between
all of those clouds
and it never recognizes what the shared
eternal awareness
is and so
what happens in these first even 20
minutes which is so
interesting is that the
lightning that we're talking about it
draws you away
from the gross physicalism
and it drives you more towards the
subtlety of your awareness and your
consciousness
and just even feeling your body just
becoming
more and more light and it's fascinating
because
you begin in a sense feeling the parts
of your body that
really badly want to just
go and lay down and stretch
and lay in the sun and as we talked
about
in our episode on fasting that we did
herbert shelton allen goldhammer
especially the idea of helio hygienics
sunbathing and air bathing and so you're
literally
just out laying down in the sunlight
boom within right after that light
feeling kicks in
and so that's sort of the
ambiance is just laying out on a couple
cushions out on the
backyard sunlight and
taking these notes with these time
stamps
as the experience goes on
and so there was also this
as you feel light what also happens is
the
as we were saying neuroscientifically
that
the release of the default mode network
to enable all of these new novel
neural connectomics to occur
is what makes it so that what you
normally thought was
just freaking useless
now becomes something that drops your
jaw
and that's why i write here
even just 30 minutes in that
when was the last time you saw a leaf
blow
off of a tree
or that wind blows a leaf
and it rustles along the concrete
and we've become so numb to not
experiencing awe to any of these
that we don't even notice it and
it keeps us in this gross physicalism
rather than in the beauty of the subtle
non-dual
infinite creative expression
and you'll notice that i do this a lot
i roll my thumb with my fingers
and it's because that in a sense is like
what happens with water
this in many ways is an ocean
this is emptiness appearing as the
oceanic infinitude with us as
little fish inside of that oceanic
infinitude
and the awareness is eternal and shared
among the fish
and the emptiness appearing is only
going to keep appearing as more and more
infinite combinations as
these dreamed creation designs like this
planet earth orbiting the star
and so in a sense this also represents
subtlety
this is subtlety when gross physicalism
is like
you can't feel your own heartbeat let
alone the subtlety
of a one mile per hour wind
and so that's why immediately
with that
relaxation that happens
feeling lighter you begin noticing
immediately what you hadn't been
noticing before
only when you sit quietly and
as patanjali said yoga [ __ ] of riti
nirodha
that you quiet the mind enough
those fluctuations so that you can
actually feel the union with the
infinite that that's
what enables you to feel that subtlety
and
entheogens like magic mushrooms they
just go and they drop you
in there as is being discovered in the
synthesis of science and spirituality
what used to take meditators very long
periods of time to be able to in a sense
gain the skills to be able to drop into
said states
that boom that you can drop in with an
antiogen which is fantastic
and very awakening and very healing as
well
and so here you'll notice i wrote atlas
is gone again
which is something that is really
it's just kind of like a boop like it's
gone again like the unit the atlas unit
the atlas
character it it kind of like
occasionally comes in when someone says
you know
hey you know they send you a message and
they want you to do something and so you
know you send them a message back
or on a phone call or whatever or even
in person somebody asks you to do
something
right but when you're alone and you're
undergoing this microdose the atlas
unit is completely gone you are just
one with the ocean you are
the one infinite creator expressing
itself and experiencing itself
and that's it and so all these layers of
identity around your name
who you are your profession your
background
all this stuff fades away nobody gives a
[ __ ]
about any of those identifiers anymore
entheogens take you directly to the
kingdom of god within you they
show you the kingdom of god around you
they show you the very fact that you
are in the ocean of infinity expressing
itself
and zip all of those layers of identity
just fall away like onion layers down to
that
very subtle infinitude non-dual
infinitude
so around 1 15
i'm just sitting there bathing in the
sun and again
herbert shelton is very adamant
about bathing in the sun helio hygenics
go and lay out on some cushions every
single day for 30 minutes
and roll in naked by the way naked or
you know in some boxers or underwear or
basketball shorts or whatever if you
can't naked
but the point is take off your shirt
take off your top take off your pants
take off your sock stick off your shoes
take off
everything and lay there in the sunlight
absorbing the sunlight and just
meditating on your very infinitude
and just being subtle enough to
recognize the birds chirping
and to recognize the squirrel that's
jumping through the
the branches of the trees and to be
subtle enough to
feel the wind at one mile per hour that
just
gently blows that leaf across the
concrete
and to be able to see those things and
to
not just run past them in the crazy nine
to five economic machinery
hump
is so important remember in the movie
soul by pixar which we did a visual film
review of
that the importance
of even the most simple
subtle experiences on planet earth
like being able to see the leaf
fall off of a tree and just spin its way
downward
that can be awe inspiring
the very fact of life your 20 000
breaths
per day that you inhale that come from
the photosynthesis of phytoplankton and
trees
that level of interdependence to
understand that and to
appreciate that and to have gratitude
and love for it
that simple aw for even what we normally
breeze past
that's another key thing that entheogens
that
magic mushrooms will show you
and the breathing and the stretching of
the body you're laying there
and you're being told
oh this part of your back
this part of your hips this part of your
knee this part of your neck and so
you're literally being
guided by the magic mushrooms
for you to
properly stretch the places in your body
ah and breathe through that stretching
process
so that you no longer feel tight there
i mean that is so profound that we are
so
gross and physical every single day
that we don't even we just wake up and
slam
coffee and get behind a computer
bruh come on
wake up go and lay
out in the sun for 30 minutes stretch
your body just breathe and just be
and drink some hot water in the morning
like has been practiced in the east for
so long
some body temperature water drink that
and then go out and sunbathe and then
come back in
and then if you want maybe
you can dose a little bit less on the
caffeine maybe you can skip some of the
computer
right away and you can go and jump into
a book for an hour
really sacredly guard the divinity
of your time
and the way that you
spiritually ground yourself and connect
every single morning and night
distance yourself from the gross
physicalism of the economic machinery
that's constantly
pounding and rather take a step inward
towards the subtlety towards the sun
towards infinitude in the morning and at
night and even throughout the day
take that hour break after you've been
on the computer and go and lay in the
sun for 10 minutes again
stretch your body again take good care
of yourself and you'll literally
live moment to moment healthier and
happier and also
longevity wise live longer
it's very much like being and not doing
it's very beautiful just laying there
and bathing in the sun just
being in infinitude rather than doing
there's like this task positivity that
we talk about a lot in the neuroscience
nomenclature
where there's this constant doing
that has to be done you're always doing
things
and to sort of take a step back and
relax away from doing tasks
is the being and that's why so many of
the greatest geniuses that have ever
lived have talked very
dearly about that sinking back inward
towards being aware of awareness
and just allowing the intuition
to lightning bolt in and then you'll
profoundly be able to actually solve
some of those challenges that you were
focused on for hours but couldn't solve
and we have this very great quote that
we've been saying for a while thanks to
tony robbins the quality of your life is
the quality of your questions
which is really true and really
important that the more profound your
questions are
the better the quality of your life is
how do i
maximize my own well-being in the
planet's well-being
what is the i is that eternal is that
shared what is my metaphysical truth
quality questions but the quality of
your life is also the quality that you
stop and smell
the flowers
do you know how to enjoy every single
note
in the symphony
because right now the most egoic the
most gross
physical people they
are only seeking the destination
have no interest whatsoever in every
single musical note
and the silence between them in the
journey itself
you don't listen to a symphony just to
hear the last note
the last note no the symphony
[Music]
and is listening to every single note
profoundly
and feels great
and so life is then about smelling the
flowers
literally when you walk literally
look around you block to block are there
flowers poking out of these houses yes
there are
okay cool stop smell
that red flower that white flower smell
the lavender
smell the different bushes and flowers
that you see around you on your walks
stop and smell those the more that you
do that the more you'll actually feel
alive
at the very very end of the day atlas is
a creative anarchic expression of
infinity and so are you all of
this is a creative anarchic expression
of infinity
and it's just going to continue being
that way it's been that way it's going
to continue being that way that is what
is meant by the tao
like lao tzu said that's what's meant by
brahman
in the advaita vedanta tradition that
the
truth that the knowledge that that veda
is the recognition that i am the
ultimate
that this is the ineffable ultimate
absolute
expressing itself eternally
and then other funny things like seeing
the little ant
that at its scale is kind of like moving
pretty quickly like looks like it's
running
but to me it looks like it's just
crawling to a human it looks like damn
that ant's moving hella slow
but at its level at its scale on the
more micro level it's
usain bolt over there so funny
and so then this realization came up
everything is so
unbelievably perfect everything is so
indescribably
perfect everything is so ineffably
perfect
it's hilarious how blind we are to it
and yet civ is also simultaneously out
of its mind
this is what i'm talking about regarding
the subtlety of infinity the subtlety of
non-duality the subtlety
of an ineffable perfection that we
always
are
you are the piece in the jigsaw puzzle
that always
fits you are it
i am it see i and my father
are one john 10 30.
we are that eternal infinitude
expressing itself
anarchically creatively and to recognize
that your nature
is the peace and joy of
that simply appearing
and happening
that is all that is meant by
enlightenment recognize your eternal
shared awareness
among us all our nature of that is peace
the nature of that is joy and then weave
that realization
into the social fabric into the dreamed
creation design
and the absolute realization is to
recognize that even the
agent that is dreamed
the seer itself
is a dreamed agent that you can pluck
like the last
thorn and then recognize the agentless
attributeless
absolute ineffable all of this is
indescribably perfect
it's all so gorgeous
and yet we are so blind to it
we're always seeking for something to be
fulfilled
something has to happen for me to be
happy something has to happen for me to
feel
peace when actually it's the exact
opposite of that
that you are peace and happiness and you
bring that
to the dreamed creation design
even through all of the misery the
billion people that still don't have
access to clean water clean food
the geopolitical turmoil all of the
worry around
artificial general intelligence and bio
and neuro
engineering and technology
even through all of that the planetary
ecological catastrophes we are still
perfect exactly the way we are
everything is perfect
and yet we're also architecting towards
well-being and prosperity and abundance
at the same
time that's what's meant by true
simultaneity of that non-dual perfection
while the dualistic concession of we're
architecting away from suffering towards
well-being and prosperity
and that's why i say civ is also out of
its mind because
the amount of noise
that is plaguing our civilization is
crazy
we have these great information
technology vehicles that exist now
but to be able to find the signal
requires
a razor-like precision and intelligence
and also very gatekeeping away from all
of the clouds of noise like polarization
propaganda fast food all of that kind of
nonsense
that doesn't serve us
and then i wrote this that boop before
you know it you're back in the dirt
like scrubbing all the way through a
timeline or movie
imagine your life timeline and then
click like it's in
premiere or in final cut or any of the
editing softwares
and just click and go from the beginning
all the way to the end
in just one second you can drag back
and forth and watch yourself go from a
zygote to a 30 trillion cell human adult
to in the grave
before you know it you're in the dirt
learn to respect every single
note in the symphony
around 123 this came up a billion years
from now
nobody will give a [ __ ] about your
anxiety
think about it at that scale make the
best
of your life
at that scale a billion years from now
in these
next creation designs that infinite will
express itself as
nobody's gonna give a [ __ ] about your
anxiety nobody even gave a [ __ ] about
somebody's anxiety from a hundred years
ago
let alone a thousand years ago nobody
gave a [ __ ] about their anxiety
today so nobody's going to give about
your anxiety in even
50 or 100 years so
stop with the anxiety love yourself
accept yourself
quiet the mind recognize yourself as the
one infinite creator
and then weave your profound
realizations into the social fabric and
maximizing our planetary prosperity
love and accept yourself there's no
reason to be anxious
there's no reason to not love yourself
you are the one infinite creator
expressing itself you
are love already recognize that diamond
necklace already
around your neck
so again simply this appearance
happening
again very important that people like
jim newman came on the show and ended up
just very simply putting it
simply this appearance happening
done non-duality
and surrendering the primal is so
important
because you're always going to get the
proclivity this tendency to want to go
and eat
you want to eat and shovel food into
your mouth you want to eat refined
sugars
you want oils and salts and you want to
you want to focus on just you know
having sex because those are the two
greatest reward functions of sex and
food
and so you're just you know it's just
like this craving to have that
and so you have to learn how to distance
yourself from those primal needs
learn how to fast from food but also
learn how to fast
from the incessant drive to have sex
learn how to fast from the digital
space having those detoxes
learn how to bathe in the sun and to
read books
and be come in service of stewardship
butterfly affect the most consciousness
to awaken
meaning that by focusing on the
stewarding of consciousness
in serving the planetary prosperity to
help
meet the basic needs for other people to
turn inward and awaken themselves to
being the one infinite creator
that is the most
highest moral expression that you can be
is to be in absolute highest service
morally and ethically and spiritually
and
architecturally to maximize prosperity
that's why ramana maharshi said that the
greatest service that you can render
human
kind is to god realize
recognize yourself as that one infinite
creator so become a steward of
consciousness
rather than becoming somebody that seeks
the instant gratification
and fails the marshmallow experiment is
always pursuing salt oil sugar
or sex delay the gratification
towards the two marshmallows of
stewarding consciousness
and that's why it's called the light
switch
that's why when you flick the light
switch
on what happens is that you
gain a mostly a dark room
will become light
and so that's what you're doing is
you're
you're a vessel for the darkness
to become light your mirror of the god
state is so
pure that it's constantly reflecting
to the more dirty mirrors of
existence that hey awaken to yourself as
the god state
through questions through love
unconditional wisdom and grace that you
have like a
jedi in your conversations and
everything you do
where other people can very easily
become more and more awakened
switch from that darkness to the light
so 127 we're approaching that first hour
in i'm getting the eternal fireworks
again it's all just eternal fireworks
like francis lucille said
it is all eternal fireworks infinite
fireworks
and to recognize that every note in the
symphony is
fireworks that is it that's
enlightenment
and to weave that realization into the
social fabric that's the tantric path
that's sahaja samadhi
that's as buddha said the middle way the
middle path
it's very much like bodhisattva that you
don't just go
and [ __ ] off and completely
ignore the civilizational social fabric
but that you
dive in with your realizations into the
social fabric
and maximize its potential
the profundity of the simple question
what's the rush
ask yourself is this four means to an
end am i running just to finish the run
or every single breath on my run
am i enjoying the process
every note in that symphony same thing
am i at work
just for the 5 p.m clock out
am i attending the symphony for just the
last note
enjoyment that is the key simply
enjoyment enjoyment
in plus joy plus moment
you're in joy in the moment
joy in the moment joy
in the moment joy joy joy
peace peace peace ah
eternal fireworks
all right so here's about that hour mark
in the most ultimate none of this ever
happened
like a bubble passing through the air
and then
pops so when you blow a bunch of bubbles
like a kid
and you see the bubble this is our
bubble universe bubble universe and then
it goes and goes and floats a little
more and then
it hits the ground or pops in the air
and
at the level of the infinite
mandelbrot fractal zoom that there's so
many of these bubble universes that are
being made
and just multiverses galore of all of
these different
combinations of underlying emptiness
appearing as
form and matter in these dream creation
designs
you'll never come to the end of all of
the different possibilities on a color
palette
or in binary code or in musical notes
in a song and so that's what all these
little multiverses are
and so this one itself is like a bubble
that passes and pops
and then infinity's continuing to
express itself
eternally so in the most ultimate none
of this ever happened
like a bubble passing through the air
and then pops
even the observer itself is dreamed and
that's the absolute realization
even you as the seer in that god
realized state
recognized yourself as being a dreamed
agent of
infinity and then you're like oh [ __ ]
even the sears dreamed
147 mood was coming up as a cool word
because
right now a lot of the social platforms
don't really have a good way to be able
to filter by mood
i think that's a big part of our future
when you do things like walk into the
home and there's a biometric
psychometric
sensor that detects the state of the
body
and if it's in a state that wants to
relax chill the [ __ ] out
you'll get a little spray of lavender in
the room
you'll get a little a little
musical ambiance that helps with the
relaxation
you get the warm cup of tea that's
already ready for you
and then you just lay the back
and so similarly the mood on social as
well if you want to get inspired you
want a specific piece of content relax a
piece of content
learn new knowledge a piece of content
and so all feeds being tailored by these
three groups
found that to be interesting 154 was
thinking about this non-dual shirt we're
playing around with
merchandise right now and so the idea
nothing really matters on a shirt with
the atomic design
in the background is kind of cute
because technically
matter is only an appearance
and at the most underlying level it's
simply
energy modulating and so
that's fascinating so nothing really is
matter
and then also nothing really matters in
the non-dual
infinite eternal anarchic creative
expression
as well and it's beautiful because
we get to say that you know this atlas
unit
running the simulation enlightenment
media channel it's a lot of fun
you know and it's great in the moment
you can say that this is cool and this
is fun and that it matters and that it's
cute and that it's playful and that
we're having a fun time sharing this but
in
the 1 billion years from now style
conversation no
none of this mattered none of this
happened and that it's on to its next
expressions of infinity
eternally and that's what's been
happening that's what's going to
continue happening that's what's meant
by one infinite creator expressing
itself
you can think about it like did the
secretion of a plant
in the middle of a forest
that has no humans
or animals or insects
or even other plants around it
did that matter that's just like you
that's a micro example of you
and again that's not to be nihilistic
nihilism has its own
negative connotation and baggage it's
not to say that
it's more to say that recognize it at
both the level of quantum mechanics that
nothing really matters
and also at the level of one infinite
creator expressing itself that this is
fun
lila as they say in sanskrit the divine
play
which is beautiful but also it doesn't
matter
but it's beautiful and it's creative and
it's fun and we
are maximizing human potential while
we're here
that's the difference between that and
the negative baggage and connotation
with nihilism
and this was coming through to look up
look up at the sky look up
at your potential look up at our
potential look up
and how beautiful it is to just be
looking at the sky and to see
those different modulations and cloud
formations recognizing that your
thoughts are just like that
and that you're the sky in which they
happen the eternal shared awareness
but then also seeing that there's so
many birds that fly overhead that
chirp there's some that come in just one
at a time or two at a time or sometimes
they come in like
batches of 50 at a time some of them are
chirping some are not
some of them are within just 10 or 20
feet of your head some of them are
100 or more feet above you
and so the ability to sort of be able to
see those nuances and subtleties
just by looking up is critical and also
looking up in terms of your potential
never looking down and just scrunched up
and crunched up like
oh i'm so worthless i'm so hopeless
our civilization is so screwed
none of those thoughts ever served
anybody ever
all of they do all those thoughts do is
create cancerous pathologies for
yourself
and others so rather look up stand up
straight and tall with your shoulders
back like jordan peterson says
and go and bring yourself most fully to
the god
actualized realized state as well as the
unique expression
of that infinitude outward
and then next what came up was blah blah
blah none of this [ __ ]
matters again in the very ultimate state
you can think of every single word
that's coming right now to you
as blah blah
blah blah blah
because that would then change every
single word that's being communicated to
something that literally doesn't matter
every single word being something that
doesn't matter
and that's also the subtlety of
recognizing infinity expressing itself
but also in the dualistic concession the
reason why
we're using words right now to even
communicate all this profundity around
anthogens and around enlightenment and
around non-duality and infinity
is because it works for sharing
the message to other people just like i
was on the receiving end several months
ago
where i was taking in these messages and
then going like
oh [ __ ] the diamond is already around
our necks
and slowly getting that more and more
and
achieving that god realized state
recognizing oneself as the one infinite
creator and dissolving the contracted
finite
egoic separate biological entity energy
and that's why true simultaneity is key
in the most non-dual
anarchic creative expressionary sense of
the infinite
none of it matters but in your current
state
of dreamed agent experience right now
it matters for you to love yourself and
accept yourself because you don't want
the state of
valence of suffering you deserve the
state of valence of well-being and
enlightenment
and also your family and friends don't
deserve the state surveillance
of you having anger and frustration
and yelling and that's why the buddha
taught how to eradicate the roots of
suffering and misery by leveraging the
breath
recognizing one's own true nature
through the breath
eradicating those roots so that no
longer
this is where a lot of the neo advaita
tradition has been kind of hitting heads
with a lot of the more
perennial mystic wisdoms which is that
you can't just go from a
state of being a contracted finite
biological separate entity
to recognizing that oh this is all just
a dream
and then saying that i've achieved the
state of recognizing that this is all
the absolute expressing itself because
then what's going to happen is
you're going to go back out into the
world and something's going to trigger
you
because you've never practiced what
buddha has taught
you've never practiced what jesus has
taught what lauzo or confucius have
taught that's why
zoroaster and all of these most biggest
teachers of the absolute highest
morality of the inward path
that they will explicitly mention
that you have to take these steps
more and more like repetitions again
this like neo advices sometimes can be
thought of as going to the gym
and just repping at the bench
one time 200 pounds and you're like
huh dope and then it's like i got it
actually no it's
for you to be able to recognize how to
like i did when i was in high school to
work my way
up from just the bar to adding five
pounds on each side 10 pounds on each
side
20 pounds on each side and working my
way up just like in the weight room
is just like with that light bulb that
flickers
and then it boom satori stays
on and that's when you can't actually
have any more anger
or frustration anymore and this is what
was talked about with
jim newman and sam harris on sam
harris's recent
podcast conversation with him where you
can't
actually have the non-dual recognition
and be angry that's what enlightenment
is
not knowing that this is non-duality and
still
when somebody cuts you off in traffic
being like screw you
then then there is no enlightenment
there
the enlightenment is when somebody cuts
you off in traffic and you
literally have the pause the breath and
the pause
and then saying something like that
person could potentially be in a rush
maybe they're in a rush to get to the
hospital
to bring somebody there and so it's
having
that level of awareness that that is
also your shared consciousness that's in
that car cutting you
off and so
this is really important
that non-duality can't be coupled with
anger
the true enlightened realization that
has been talked about for millennia
is when the truest deepest roots of
suffering and misery are
eradicated and the non-dual realization
is realized
that's what it is
and this was really interesting like a
little bit over an hour and a half
in this came up
the non-dual cameo appearance is
captured by
chimps with iphones and i wrote this is
the most ridiculous [ __ ] i've written in
my life
and then i wrote the non-dual secretion
of chimps with iphones
right because it's kind of like the
the non-dual infinite expresses itself
in this dream creation design as the
secretion
of the entheogens and the dreamed
landscape and the
chimps that evolve into humans and that
then
turn back around on the nature of their
existence on the infinite and wonder
oh we are that doing this and they get
that that's what the god
realized state is and then it's funny
because then you use these devices
and then you capture the chimps
in the infinite so in this case the
chimps are the humans
right and humans take iphones and then
they
take selfies of themselves and they take
pictures of other people
and so we are the infinite as chimps
evolve to humans that then create the
technology of iphones to take pictures
of themselves
in the infinite to know themselves
through these pictures of themselves in
the infinite
so it's like the infinite is taking
pictures of itself
that's what i'm talking about right now
literally every time we take a photo of
ourselves and other people
it is the infinite taking pictures of
itself
and so now you can imagine all of the
different infinite photos that can be
taken
and that's what this is eternally taking
iphone photos across different dreamed
landscapes with different dreamed
agents that's why
a couple years ago it was a while ago
now maybe even five years ago
i was like 23 or something and i was
talking about how this
flesh vehicle looks good on me
right so the infinite at that time i
didn't recognize that that's what it was
that the infinite
recognizing that this vehicle
of its creation looks good on itself
take a little photo now
the non-dual cameo appearance
is captured by chimps with iphones
that's so funny so about two hours in
now
i'm starting to get these realizations
that a lot of people
this is very related to the last point
are dealing with their extended
phenotypes
as richard dawkins says is that
everything that's happening on the
internet especially with social media
profiles is like our extended phenotype
that people are posting their absolute
best selves on there so that they can
procure the absolute best mates and so
that they can procure the absolute best
businesses
to give them money and friends and
relationships
and so what's happening is that when we
take the steps of digital detox
we disassociate ourselves from that
extended phenotype
no you don't need to reply to your
messages the same day
no you don't need to post to ig
or youtube or tiktok or any of the
social platforms
every single day and you don't need to
consume other people's content every
single day
you can take time to just
be and take time to reflect inward
on what your true nature is and to
tap into the subtleties that we've been
talking about and the disassociation
from that extended phenotype is really
critical in that process
so a little bit over two hours and now
we're back to the basics is what came up
because that's the question
what is it and as the character came up
from the heroic dose as well it's
the what
else reality
what is it oh what is it
and that character asking the simple
question
what is it what is it
what is reality
what else
a reality
what is it
and to really get to that basic question
what is it
what is reality who
am i what is the i why are we here
one infinite creator expressing itself
hey
one infinite creator expressing itself
and you get to these understandings and
these
[Music]
true recognitions of intelligent
infinity and you
are that
so what is i it's an expression that's
turned inward and it's asking questions
about its own nature
that's the awakened eye is turned inward
asking questions about its own nature
recognizing its own nature
and that's what's meant by the parable
of the prodigal son turning inward
whereas the contracted separate finite
egoic biological entity
is running only outward and not even
recognizing its own true nature
and then hits all of the breaking points
of greed and seeking happiness and peace
externally
conspicuous consumption chasing fame and
clout
chasing material possessions
so at 309
i'm in the backyard and i'm up and
moving around a bit and we have this
little kumquat tree and we have this
little orange tree
and it's interesting because i go and i
pick a kumquat and i'm really slow with
eating and i'm really slow with eating
the orange
it was interesting i took the orange
into
the kitchen and i
whipped out the cutting board and the
knife just to make it easier to open
and eat i was like i could have easily
just opened the orange
in the backyard and so there's this
interesting sort of recognition that
we've created this
additional knife and cutting board
situation for opening the orange
that we could also open with just our
hands that was interesting
but those the kumquat and the orange
from the trees in the backyard tasted
incredible
and then i went inside into the kitchen
and i ate
grapes from the fridge
and they tasted like they were forced
yelled at by the economy to grow
it was so interesting because my uncle
specifically and even my mom has been
telling me for a while
they're like you can taste the
difference between
a tomato that is organic
and that is coming from a region where
it's actually
extracting really good amounts of
nutrients from the soil
and you can tell also by taste a tomato
that tastes like cardboard
that the economy was just yelling at it
to grow faster
and extracting no nutrients out of the
soil
and back then a couple years ago i
couldn't taste so much the difference
but then i grew more and more into it
and especially now
wow you can really taste the difference
and it's really
important for us to recognize that we
have to become more
permaculturally driven we have to
understand
how to extract the absolute most
nutrients out of the soil
feed the entire planet and then
rejuvenate those parts of the world
and that's going to be really important
especially here in the central valley in
california
that produces
two-thirds of the fruits and nuts for
the united states and one-third of the
vegetables
and in order for us to
continue at that rate of production we
have to be very permaculturally
intelligent
and so at 333 my friend skye
uses the number 555 which is fascinating
i was like maybe 333 is my number i like
the idea of just kind of like three
numbers that
you can write on you know skye had it on
a sheet of paper on that quote on the
back 555 and you knew that that was him
from him so i was like maybe three three
three can be from me
and i was thinking you can bathe in the
sun all day
and stay clear of the economic machinery
i was like
is that's why there are so many homeless
in california one of the big reasons is
because
of the weather we can bathe in the sun
all day
and steer clear of the economy because
we can just live
in tents
and in the cars and rvs and campers and
stuff like that
and this kind of follows the indigenous
vibe
one should be able to just live and be
without the need to earn money and live
this is very similar to the 12 film as
well
which i loved having both sophie and
olivier on the program because
the recognition that these indigenous
cultures from around the planet
and in this case in the film there were
12 of them cultures
that many of them
especially i believe the botswanan tribe
from
africa made a big joke
about the fact that humans in the metros
have to go and sell
eight hours of their day to earn sheets
of paper
to then go and exchange that for
the roof over their head and for food
they thought that was ridiculous
because the indigenous elders there
they live on the land and they harvest
food from the land and there's plenty of
abundance doing that
and so i was like dude that's freaking
crazy the difference
between the metro economic machinery
versus the indigenous vibe and in many
ways there are
some mental health issues and many other
things that are happening with
homeless yet the recognition that
many people choose to
live in a way that follows more of the
indigenous vibe of
i will not be a slave to the economic
machine
and then at 3 43 like three hours in i
had this tennis curb workout that i did
i took my
pocket disc out i took a tennis ball out
and i started throwing it at the
at the driveway curb and catching and
shuffling it throwing it repeating and
staying in this flow
it kind of looks like this
you basically you basically take your
tennis ball and what you do
is you take it on the driveway curb that
angles downward and you throw the tennis
ball
while you're standing at the exact angle
on the curb that makes it so that the
tennis ball bounces
off of the driveway curb and comes back
into your hand
and then you shuffle to the other
driveway curb and then you throw the
tennis ball with your other hand at the
driveway curb and so you're just
throwing the tennis ball
at the angled driveway curb and catching
it
and it's a really good workout
and i'll probably be sharing some more
content about that soon because it's a
really interesting and good
workout for hand-eye coordination and
for movement
and then after that
we come to the wrap because i like to
take a shower after the anthogenic
experiences
obviously i was sunbathing a lot and
sweating and all this other kind of
stuff and moving around but
in the shower it was kind of beautiful
just again
just you know this is really the tail
end of the four hour experience
and i'm just hitting the hot water
right on the top of the head and looking
at the little
shaving mirror that i have in there and
just
recognizing the sheer ineffability and
perfection and beauty of that hot water
that's just
running on the head and just dripping
all over the body and just being so
grateful for
all the architects engineers designers
operations people civil engineers that
have come through
to build the protocols that have made it
so simple for us to be able to just go
and turn on
the hot water and have that and just
looking at myself in the pupil and
laughing
and recognizing myself as infinity
expressing itself and playing this funny
game
that i guess is now being called mouth
drums
where you basically it's such a funny
childlike game
[Music]
and so playing around with the mouth
drums was fun doing that in the shower
and just really recognizing
that we have this child like creativity
and awe
with us all the time but how many
corporate adults could ever go like
and how many corporate adults could ever
go like what
he was a reality
and if we're not
going to be able to express ourselves
that way we're going to create zombies
in an economic machine
which is what we have zombies in an
economic machine
and rebels that want art
and ecological harmony and childlike
creativity
and prosperity for all
ecological harmonics
geopolitical peace the eradication of
nuclear weapons
recognition of ourselves as one infinite
creator expressing itself
our priorities need to be in that
direction
rather than in the direction of what is
in many ways
just an extractive cogs in machines
that are filling some sort of a perverse
incentive need
of corporations to just grow and
create shareholder revenue which then go
and purchase luxury goods for those said
shareholders
that's an absolute disaster where are
the ethics where are the morals
that then have the checks in place
that's why we created the american
antiquities act of 1906 with teddy
roosevelt and john muir
to have the national park service
protect the united states's most
beautiful parks
so that there weren't perverse
incentives that came in and just
destroyed
all of the forests and destroyed all of
the natural resources
same thing with the sackler family in
purdue pharma and the opiate epidemic
is that when you don't have checks on
the perverse incentives
you're gonna get a bunch of people that
come in and extract
out money from people's maximum
well-being and potential
so we have to recognize how to architect
our protocols to prevent that from
happening
and also to maximize our fullest
prosperity and
recognition of the one infinite creator
child like play
all of this and that was the end four
hours
total elapsed time on a one gram
magic mushroom micro dose
of the albino
penis envy and we've been making a good
amount of
anthogenic content across our tick tock
that has been getting a good amount of
views one of the videos almost got a
million views which was so
interesting and some of the other ones
have gotten several hundred thousand
views which has been cool
and we'll keep making content about
anthogens across those platforms and
i'll probably keep doing these trip
reports
across the different entheogens
i think they're really important to
mainstream and popularize
people being comfortable with talking
about anthogens and what they do
and also specifically magic mushrooms
is such a like we were saying earlier
it's so
subtle especially on a micro dose of a
gram
to be able to take that in and then have
just a four hour
experience for like half of a day and
have a
profound connection to nature and to
infinity
into your own awareness and expression
of that
and again huge shout out to sky and
sunny and the healing hustlers again
check out the link in the bio
reach out to them if you'd like to place
an order here in the us
and
likely soon across the world because a
lot of our audience is watching from the
uk
and germany and australia and even india
and lots of other places so
shout out to all of the homies from
across the planet
we love you very much
thanks everybody for tuning in to the
trip report like the video if it brought
you value subscribe if you haven't yet
would love that helps us a lot
helps with the youtube algorithm as well
and comment below with your thoughts
would love to hear from you and if you'd
like to you can join the channel
as well and gain great benefits as a
member
and also support all of our
actualization of our projects and share
the video with other people that you
feel like this would bring a profound
influence on and thank you so much
adore you infinite love and
one infinite creator expressing itself
you gotta go inward first to go
outward or right it's the sure cause of
delight
and leverage antiogens to help assist
on the inward first to go outward right
recognize oneself as that one infinite
creator leverage and theogens
create more of these trip reports place
orders
for magic mushrooms 5mu dmt explore
and play adore you thank you
and also shout out to maps as well
the multidisciplinary association for
psychedelic studies that's been doing
incredible work
they got breakthrough therapy
designation they've been healing many
people
and we've interviewed rick goblin the
founder and executive director on the
show several times
and so we'll also put their link in the
bio for you to check out and give them a
support
even at five or ten dollars is such a
big contribution to them
is so important so do support them
we love you thank you